- So one of the reasons that I was
really excited to do this is
cuz obviously I'm combining
two of my favorite things:
sports and movies.
- OK.
- So we have to start there
with your top five sports movies,
and they have to be in order.
- Oh, that's tough. In order?
- Yes.
- Um—
- Cuz, you know, the copout
is just to say them all.
You gotta rank the sports movies.
- I gotta rank the sports movies. OK.
I'm going with...No. 1...
oh, man. "White Men Can't Jump."
- Great, great start.
- No. 2, I'mma go with
"Any Given Sunday."
3, I'm going with "Sandlot."
- Mm.
- 4, I'm gonna go with...
"Remember the Titans." And 5,
I'mma go with "Hardball." I'm biased.
- Yeah, gotta pick "Hardball."
- Yeah, yeah.
- There is a big one missing,
but this is all opinion.
There was no, "He Got Game."
- Oh, man, yes.
- Yeah, see, I'mma save you there.
There was no "He Got Game."
- "He Got Game." Yes, all right. I'll swap,
I'll swap "Remember the
Titans" and "He Got Game."
- OK.
- Yeah.
- All right.
Are we missing any other big ones?
I mean, are you like a, are you
like a "Major League"?
Are you a "Jerry Maguire"?
Are you any of—?
- Ah, they don't really rank.
I was gonna say "Space Jam 1."
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
Just as a straight classic,
but I don't know. "Field of Dreams" was,
I guess, does that count? That counts, right?
- Yeah, that counts.
- Yeah.
- Such an unrealistic plot—
- "Mighty Ducks."
- Like, that's a good one.
- There's too many.
- Yes.
- But your list is solid.
So I'll take that.
- OK.
- And we can start there.
Yeah, you passed that test.
You started with a really
good one, "White Men Can't Jump."
You have to, you have to
begin with that, and you put
"He Got Game" in there. So
it all worked out.
- OK.
- But you of course were
in "Friday Night Lights."
You did a sports TV show.
- Mmhmm.
- What do you like doing
better, TV shows or movies?
- I think—that's a good question.
I think it evolved over time.
I used to enjoy doing
television because it gave,
it gave the actor time to
develop and grow the character.
It gave time for the audience
to actually fall in love with
the character.
Look, I don't know how much, like, sympathy
and empathy you would have
for, like, Wallace on "The Wire"
if it was only like one episode, you know?
Rather than, you know,
an entire season to be able to
kinda like, really, like, make
his death that much more tragic
and meaningful, you know?
- Yeah.
- And then I think there was a
time where I didn't know if I
could open a film or
carry a movie, you know?
Was I a leading man?
So, like, "Fruitvale" kinda
answered a lot of
those questions for me at
a young, at a, you know, younger age.
And I enjoyed, you know, a
beginning and an end, you know?
I kinda know where I'm going
so I can arc a character out.
I could actually, like, be
intentional with my choices,
knowing where I'm gonna go. In TV,
you don't really know
where the next season's
gonna take you.
You don't know what the, you know,
what's really gonna happen
with your character.
So you're just, you're in the moment.
So I think it's just a
different muscle and a want.
And I think now at this
age, you know,
you're looking for, you know,
the best material.
- Mmhmm.
If it's a character that's
really rich and interesting,
I might want more time.
- I think that movies leave
you feeling satisfied.
- Mmhmm.
- But there is something very
intimate about television shows
because you're almost inviting
those people into your home,
right? Like, every single week on Wednesday
or whatever the day is, I'm
hanging out with these people.
And I feel like I know them.
- Exactly.
- And there's just,
there is more of a connection there,
but I don't know if you
always feel as full.
So there's something nice about
having this full character
that's in a movie.
- Yeah.
- You said something
interesting talking about
when you were doing "Fruitvale Station."
- Mmhmm.
- You said that you would ask
yourself, "Am I a leading man?"
- Mmhmm.
- When did you get that definitive
answer that you were a
leading man?
And how long did you
struggle with that question?
- That's a good question.
I think...
I think that, on paper, answered
the question with, you know,
the success that movie
had. I think probably
"Creed 1," for me, really
kinda, it kinda resonated a bit more.
I think there's a lot of, like,
an imposter syndrome that
followed during that time
of figuring out, you know,
your place in the industry,
your place in, you know,
the movie business where
you're transitioning from TV to
film, you know,
at a time where there was
a shift in, like, what was
acceptable, you know? And
yeah, you just, you know,
having faith in what you're doing.
But I think after "Creed 1,"
it started to really, like,
set in. And then, like, you know,
your family and your close
friends, they, you know,
having to remind you of where you are.
- Yeah.
I used to like try to, you know,
I don't believe my own hype.
I don't drink my own
Kool-Aid a lil' bit,
I just, you know, I like
doing the work and, you know,
and trying to be the
best version of myself.
- So there's this quote,
it's by this Greek writer
named Nikos.
- Mmhmm.
- And he said, "I once saw
a bee drown in honey,
and I understood."
And that's kind of what I think
about when I hear you say—
- That's a good one.
- You know, "I was just trying
to make sure I stayed level,
and there was all this,
like, goodness around me."
- Mmhmm.
- "And there's so many people telling
me about all this goodness
around me, but I don't want
to be overpowered by that."
But I'm sure that also, though,
is a struggle in itself too.
- It's a balance between,
like, owning your blessings
and your success in the
path that you've been on
and the things that you went
through to get what you have,
you know? And remembering
where they came from.
I think when you're living
in your purpose and you're
blessed enough to feel like
what you're doing every day is
something that you're
supposed to be doing,
you know, that's a blessing,
and you gotta live in that,
you know? All of the other
things around it start to make it
complicated.
But I think the success
and stuff just magnifies who
you really are.
- Yeah.
- You know?
Yeah, but this Hollywood
thing's a monster. You see,
you know, people, you
know—it's undefeated.
- Yeah. Yeah, it's a–I think
it's easy to get caught up
in things you probably
shouldn't be caught up in.
But one of the great things
about you, and I mean this,
I have never heard anyone say
anything other than the fact
that you are the nicest human being.
- I'll take that.
- Yeah.
Like, everyone just talks about
your smile and how kind you
are and that you're just genuine.
And I think that that shows
with things like what you're
working on now, like the
Invesco QQQ Legacy Classic,
which is gonna highlight HBCUs.
When I think about that title, though,
obviously what sticks out to
me is the legacy part of it.
And I want to talk about HBCUs,
but I want to talk a little
bit about you too first.
I know you've done a lot
of HBCU talking already.
- Mmhmm.
But how often do you think about legacy?
- All the time.
I think about legacy a lot.
You know,
when you think about things
you want to be a part of,
not just a flash in the pan,
something that's gonna stand, you know,
withstand the test of time,
that's going to be around
longer than, you know,
than my physical body is.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, life's short.
So you think about how
you want to be remembered.
Who did I help? Who did I put on?
Who did I, you know, nudge
in the right direction
so they can achieve their dreams,
you know?
- Mmhmm.
- There's, that
is, like, things that,
those are the things that I
think about, you know, a lot.
And so, you know, with,
you know, with Invesco QQQ
and the Legacy Classic,
it was an opportunity for me
to really try to pay it forward
and open up the platform and
the space for these, you know,
HBCUs that's been overlooked
for such a long time,
especially in the sports, you know...
You know, field losing, you
know, top prospects, you know,
year after year to, like,
these bigger D-I schools that,
you know, obviously, you know, the goals,
you know, for a lot of these athletes is,
you know, get to the league.
So to be able to make HBCUs
or help put them in a position
to be destination points,
- Mmhmm.
- I think was part of the way
of thinking
- Yeah.
- when it came to putting together this one.
I actually remember seeing
an interview where you said
that your greatest fear
was being forgotten.
- Mmhmm.
- Is that still true?
- Yes.
- OK, elaborate.
Came from a personal place, I guess,
of like...
it was one of my partner's
birthday who passed away when I
was younger. And it was the day
after his birthday, and I had
forgot that it was his
birthday.
- Mmm.
- And that feeling,
I was like, oh, man, OK.
Yeah, life's crazy right now,
ripping and running all over the place.
And there was a moment of like, wow, if I,
I had a moment where I actually, I forgot
that that was his birthday
and I'm, first time that's
ever happened.
That feeling of and that
realization of, you know,
mortality, and people move on
and life goes on, you know,
and people might forget
about you in moments of time.
Doesn't mean that you're not important.
Doesn't mean that the love or that bond
or that relationship wasn't there.
It's just,
- Mmhmm.
- There's the reality of that.
So that fear is something
that I think in moments...
pushes you to, you know,
to make your life worth it,
you know, to make every moment count.
To leave something behind
that you could be proud of,
that other people could
look to and be, you know, inspired by.
Yeah, I think that
those are, yeah, so that.
- Yeah.
- It's a good, yeah, yeah, forget,
yeah.
- Yeah.
- Good one.
- Claire Underwood,
great television character
- Mmhmm.
- played by Robin Wright Penn.
In an episode, she said,
"I don't want to be famous.
I want to be significant."
- Mmhmm.
- And I was like,
there actually is, like, this
small difference to that.
And I think that what you're
describing is significance.
That you want, like, you
being here to mean something,
like, much bigger than the fact that I was
this famous movie star.
- Yeah.
- But, like, there was this,
this change to that,
right?
And there's something that
is going to last forever
and leave a bigger impact.
And I think that does
start with things like
this Legacy Classic with Invesco QQQ.
So I love that. HBCU specifically,
you touched on why they are important.
Do you feel a cultural
shift happening with HBCUs?
- Definitely.
- Yeah.
- You know, I think it's
the right climate. You know,
all the stars are just, you
know, aligning in the right way
where it's having a real moment.
- Mmhmm.
- And you can't let it
pass you by, you know.
You have to, like, harness
this energy and momentum.
- Yeah.
-  And keep it moving in the right direction.
And I feel like knowing
where you came from, knowing
what's available to you,
what's in support of you.
I think we naturally started
to gravitate towards that.
And, you know, the importance
of the next generation
of how they're taught,
what they understand,
what they know about themselves.
That sense of pride is going to be very,
very crucially important to our future leaders,
- Yeah.
- you know?
And to see these young people
out here so strong, outspoken,
you know, in the thick of it.
It was very inspiring, and
it allowed me to, I don't know.
It was a moment in time that, you know...
You hear stories of like, you know,
your grandmother and your mom
and all these other things
having their moment, you
know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- And it seems...
- Oh, the old stories, yeah, I love them.
- Seems so old, you know?
And when it comes around
and was looking at you right
in the face, like, oh, this is our time.
- Yeah.
- OK, I get that.
You know, and that's a real life, you know, moment.
So,
-Yeah.
- It was cool.
- So I want to read this
quote and these stats
that I saw about HBCUs.
- Mmhmm.
- Because, yes, they are so important
to us, but HBCUs really
are vital to America.
So Black colleges account
for just 3 percent of the four-year
nonprofit colleges. Their alumni, though,
account for roughly 80 percent of Black judges,
50 percent of Black lawyers and doctors.
Their students account for
25 percent of Black undergrads who
earned degrees in STEM.
So that's important for myriad reasons.
- Yes.
- But you need Black doctors, right?
- A thousand percent.
- Because you need people
that understand us, right?
- One thousand percent.
- And the more that you have
Black people in these positions,
the more you can close
certain disparities.
- Mmhmm.
- So HBCUs really are like
a motor that is keeping us
running in a lot of spaces.
And that is so important, but I do think
the most important thing
about HBCUs existing
is that you're never
the only Black person.
- Mmhmm.
- You are always around
people that just, like,
innately understand you,
- Mmhmm.
- right?
They get the same jokes, right?
They feel the same way when
we are scrolling on our phones
and seeing Black people dying every day.
And it's important to have that
sense of community because,
so I went to a PWI. That's
predominantly white institution,
if nobody knows. Loved my
school, had a great time.
But there were so many times
I was the only Black person
in a classroom.
- And I'm sure it has happened to you too.
- Mmhmm.
being the only Black person in many rooms.
- Is there a time that you
really remember like, wow,
I'm the only Black person in this room?
- Hmm. I mean, I think [exhaling]—
I think the sad part of the
answer is that, you know,
it's been that way for such a long time,
you can't remember the first?
- 100 percent.
- You know? But there, it's a...
Like, I think we, we naturally
have become chameleons,
you know, to adapt to our
environment, to, you know,
from code-switching to whatever, right?
- Mmhmm.
- Like that's—those are the
tools that at a young age,
you learn to kind of
navigate at a certain,
at a certain point.
I think I've always had
the mindset, you know,
through my parents, you know,
of just being aware and never letting that
influence me to feel like a
victim or whatever it may be.
- Right.
- But just a sense of empowerment to use
that perception to my advantage.
- Yes.
- So it's always been a
calculating thing for me to
take those environments and
use them to my advantage,
to, you know, whether it's
Trojan horse situations,
you know what I'm sayin'?
That's, you know, where you
just, you know, quietly move in.
And next thing you know, it's,
you know, we all in here. [Laughing]
- Totally. And I mean,
and there has to be the first,
like right?
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There has to be the person
that gets this there
and can create more space for more people.
- I know 2020, of course,
is a watershed moment
for everyone.
You were super active
in all the protesting.
Tell me three ways 2020 changed you.
- Three ways 2020 changed me. Um...
I think it, and this is, you
know, probably a cliche one.
I think it, it made me realize
the importance of time and family.
- Mmhmm.
- Being able to really spend time, you know,
I'm an uncle—I'm an uncle now, so whatever.
- [Laughing] Uncle Mike!
- Uncle Mike.
- They say there's nothing like that,
like, niece, nephew love.
Like, it's just different.
- It's different.
- Yup.
- And I've never had to, I never
experienced that before, so, you know.
- I love that.
- Being able to change diapers
and be around and be present.
- Are you good?
- Yeah, I'm good.
- OK.
- I've actually got great experiences
with changing diapers.
Like, my sister's actually a
little pissed that, you know,
I've gotten like the light
diapers all the time.
- Yup.
- Literally, I've missed every blowout that's happened.
- Not a lot of poop in the diaper yet. [Laughing]
- "What?! Oh, you care about—you're
my guy. What's up, my guy? It's cool."
- Yeah, he's like, "I'm not gonna do this.
It's Uncle Mike's day. I'll hold it for tomorrow."
- Yeah, "It's Uncle Mike. I'm chillin'."
"Ma gave me corn yesterday."
I was like, "Relax, dude. Chill." Nah, nah.
- [Laughing] Oh my gosh. Have you gotten thrown up on?
- Yes.
- OK.
- I've got—yeah, I've gotten throw up and I'm cool with that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I, yeah, I deserved that one.
That was me, that was me.
- [Laughing]
- But no, he's awesome and just,
I never knew I could
love something so much
that I never had a chance to meet.
Like, literally before I even met him,
it was like, oh my God, I can't wait.
- Oh, I love it.
- And so I think family.
- OK.
- Spending time, I think that was,
that was something I
definitely learned from 2020.
Um, I've always been an introvert
and kind of being good
with being by myself.
- Yeah.
- So I think it just reinforcing,
just sitting still and getting
back to like, you know,
meditating and just resetting,
cuz last few years before that,
it's been a nonstop thing.
And, and you know, and I
was telling myself that,
yeah, after this, you know, next project,
I'm gonna take a break
for a couple of years
and I'm gonna just actually,
just work on, I'm gonna live.
I'm gonna travel.
- Have you ever taken a break?
- No.
- I didn't think so.
- No, no, no, no.
- But it's a thing that you
tell yourself to feel better.
- Yes.
- [Laughing]
- You know, I wanted to live life, you know,
instead of just watching it,
you know what I mean?
It was, and I also
wanted to experience more things
so I could, you know, have more,
more things to pull from in my work.
- Mmm. OK, that's interesting.
- You know, there's
levels to it, you know,
there's—to be able to, you know,
you gotta see more so you can, you know,
you can talk about more and
have organic places that,
of just experience, you know?
Um, so that was something that, you know,
obviously with everything else,
that couldn't happen as much, but it—
- Yeah.
- And then, yeah, so wanting to take a break,
but then I think during quarantine,
my mind and appetite changed,
and it actually made me more hungry
and focused and driven.
So coming out of when things
started to open back up, it,
I had an energy and just like
that I haven't had before.
So yeah, I think way more determined.
- I know you care
so much about your family.
I know you care so much about your legacy.
People that have money,
right, at some point,
things shift from "I want to be rich"
to "I want my family to be rich"
to "I want my family that isn't
even alive yet to be rich."
How much of a focus is
generational wealth for you?
- You've been doing your homework. These are—
- I'm always ready.
- These are thought out. No, these are good.
I think about it a lot.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I think about it a lot. I think, um, you know,
breaking that vicious cycle
of having to start over
and over and over, knowing, you know,
the family stories of
family history of, you know,
what the holidays meant to
a family, of like what debt,
you know, trying to meet this,
you know, making sure,
you know, kids aren't left out
and this and that and,
you know, doing what we can
and how that just compiles,
you know, debt.
And that's just one area,
you know what I'm saying,
of like the system that kinda,
you know, keeps us, you know,
oppressed in a lot of ways,
especially financially, you know. So—
- Yeah.
And in some ways by design.
- Almost always by design, you know?
- Yeah.
- And the education around that and lack thereof.
So I know me,
I'm learning things for the
first time that a lot of my
family hasn't had the
opportunity to be exposed to.
- Mmhmm.
- So that pressure of knowing
that and not caring about it,
I think, is irresponsible.
So, you know, yeah, there's
a motivation of, yeah,
I want these nice things or
yeah, I wanna be comfortable,
but it also comes in—it's like,
yo, I can't even enjoy this comfort
if my family's not straight.
Like, what do I look like
living here, feeling like this,
having these things—
- It would mean nothing.
Yeah.
- If they don't have that
and are able to share these
experiences with me?
And then it trickles down to
the bigger picture of, like,
you know, when I do have kids,
when I do have, you know,
grandchildren and this
and that, and, you know,
how do I make sure that they
don't have to burden the things
that I've had to experience
growing up and starting over and
having, you know, just all those things.
- Obviously money is to
buy things, at its base.
- Mmhmm.
- But what does having money,
like, signify for you?
Does that make sense? Like,
what does that mean to your life,
to your family's life,
to be able to have it?
- Giving us options.
- Yeah. Freedom.
- Freedom.
- Yeah.
- I think, you know, money signifies,
you know, in the basic sense
of just options and access
and opportunity.
- You'd mentioned growing up, tell me,
obviously the Invesco
QQQ Classic is in Newark.
- Yep.
- Tell me about your Newark.
- My Newark, my Brick City.
- Yeah.
- You know, that's why it was
really important to have,
you know, the Legacy
Classic there, you know,
at Prudential Center. Places
that I've been to growing up.
Wanting to be an example, you know,
for the community and the
kids there that, OK, cool,
that we're bringing it
back to, you know, our roots, so to speak.
I mean, my Newark is, you
know, it was fun, you know?
From, you know, hooping in the
park, you know what I mean,
to, you know, taking the
PATH over to the city
for auditions to, you know,
taking the bus home from
school and, you know,
high school parties, you
know what I'm saying?
Hit squad parties and
street teams, you know?
- OK!
- Like, the whole, like, just the whole,
you know, what
that meant was everything, you know?
- Yeah.
A lotta great people from Newark too.
Whitney Houston, from Newark.
- Mmhmm.
- I believe Shaq was born in Newark.
- Shaq's born in Newark too,
yep.
- Is Queen Latifah from Newark?
- Queen Latifah is from Newark, yeah.
- OK, yeah. So y'all produced 'em.
- We got some—
- I'm not saying it's like
Gwinnett County, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, where is that?
- Don't play me. Gwinnett County's in Georgia,
- Georgia, OK.
- Everybody coming from out there.
- OK, cool.
- We got songs about it. The North,
you know, just a lil'
somethin' somethin'. It is what it is.
But Newark is a great spot.
I've been there a bunch,
but I think that people
kind of have an idea of
what places are, but it's just
like this blip on the map.
- Mmhmm.
- They don't, like, really know
what a place is like.
Like, when I think about—
there's a basketball player,
Jalen Green. He was just drafted.
- Mm.
- He's from Fresno, California.
- Mmhmm.
- People, like, hear California,
they're like, "Oh,
this is probably some cute lil' town."
He's like, "No, Fresno—"
- Yeah.
- "Fresno not playin' witchu."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like, Fresno is a thing.
And there are parts of Newark
that are the exact same way.
- 1000 percent.
- Yeah, and I don't really know if people—
they're just like, "New Jersey,
it's near New York, whatever."
- Yeah, I mean, it's like Newark is, you know,
we got a little chip on
our shoulder, I think.
- Totally.
- I think growing up—
I think being next to
a city like Manhattan,
New York, gives you, like,
the little brother complex
a little bit.
- Mmhmm.
- It's like, "Yeah, you know,
whatchu talkin' about?"
Like, "Nah, we just as good.
We ain't got no sales tax on clothes.
Y'all be coming over here
shopping all the time."
Like, it's like we're very
proud of the things that we,
that we have and is known
for, but it makes us scrappy,
and it makes us, like, determined.
- Totally.
- I think going to, you know,
West New York or Weehawken
and looking over at the
skyline and seeing the city,
seeing those big buildings
and what that represents
of like, "Oh, I gotta get there one day.
I gotta–you know, I
want a piece of that."
You know?
- Yeah.
- I think it gives you a
motivation and a drive a bit.
But Newark is, you know,
it's tough. You know, it's,
you know, it was hard
for sure, but, you know,
it's got a lotta promise and
a lotta talent, you know,
and a lotta opportunity there as well.
You know, it just—
just the timing, you know? I think,
you know, it needs people to reinvest,
you know, back in. You know,
pour back into the city.
And I think there's places
like the Fresnos and, you know,
and the Newarks and, you know,
all these little places
that are, you know,
throughout the country that, you know,
produce talent and people that, you know,
kinda somehow make it out
of the circumstances in their
environments in a big way that, you know,
turn it back around
and be like, "All right,
how do I help reinvest
and help nurture the place
that I came from?"
You know, so—
- So—
- It's a process.
- I have to say, I hear you
talking about, you know,
reinvesting, pouring back in.
- Mmhmm.
- I think about this Classic,
giving back to the community
and, you know, this deep
love of Black people,
I can't help but think about Killmonger.
- Mmhmm.
- And after "Black Panther" came out,
I swear I had this debate
for, like, three months.
Obviously there's no definitive
answer. Opinion is opinion.
But is Killmonger a villain?
- No.
- Please tell me why. I agree.
I think, like, he's an antagonist.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But I don't know if
he's, like, a bad person.
What is your take on it?
- My take on Erik— - And I'm also so right.
I'm so happy that I can
say we agree on this.
No one agreed with me, OK?
- Yeah.
- Please continue.
You know that feeling when you're like—
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "I'm one up on you." Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How you gonna argue with Killmonger?!
All right, tell me—
- That's a good one. That's a good one.
- Gimme your take.
- No, I think, I think he was a necessary
part of the conversation.
- Yes.
- You know, I think, you know,
he cared about his people just as much as,
you know, T'Challa.
He just had a different way of
going about getting it done.
- Yeah.
- I think he was a historian that studied
history, you know? The
history of, you know,
government and oppression.
And, you know, Erik's a really smart guy,
you know what I'm saying?
MIT graduate. The guy is
like—he's very intelligent.
And he saw that there
was only really one way
to change things, you know?
So he went about that, and I
don't think his argument was
completely wrong.
I don't think T'Challa's
argument was completely wrong.
I think it was a necessary conversation
that needed to be had. But, you know,
it's a movie also.
So you gotta, you know—
- And that conversation makes it good, right?
- I'm willing to take life.
You know what I'm saying?
To do whatever it takes, you know,
and this is what I've been taught.
This is what I've been
shown that works, you know?
So you can not like it,
but there's this other version
of trying to get change done.
And it's kind of taken a
little too long for me.
I ain't got that time, you know?
And I, yeah, I guess, but
I'm doing it like this.
- Yeah. I love it.
And I totally agree.
It's like wanting of the same
thing with different methods.
I mean, maybe a little
difference in the, in the thing,
but the result is pretty similar, right?
Just the empowerment of Black people.
They both wanted that.
It's like, you know,
people always kind of do
the whole Martin and Malcolm
approach.
- Yup.
- They wanted the same thing. They just had,
they just kind of had some
different ways of going about it.
But I'm just, right now, I'm just happy.
I can't even really
focus on what you said.
- It's all good. You got that one.
You got that one.
- Yeah, this is a win for me.
And that's truly all I care about.
So I know obviously you love sports.
We got to talk about some sports.
I have something for you.
I had a friend of mine
in the Midwest, has a
little something that
they want to say to you.
So we're gonna, we're
gonna play that for you.
- Michael B. Jordan, Tom Izzo here.
- Oh, my man. OK. Izzo.
- I want to thank you so much for being a college basketball fan
and even more for being a Michigan State fan.
- Oh, that’s dope.
- We gotta get you some gears
so the next time you’re on TV, supporting the
Green and White, we’ll get you and Magic together or something.
- Oh, that's dope.
- But I also wanted
to tell you that we'd like
to invite you back to
Midnight Madness or to one of
those big games in our arena,
and the place would go crazy.
- That's nuts. You know, I've never been.
- So once again, Michael, thank you for everything you’ve done.
- You gotta go.
- Congratulations for
all the success you've had.
Keep your hand in college basketball.
- There it is. That's
awesome. That's great.
[Michael celebrating]
- You have to go. Yeah,
I got you. I got you.
You've gotta go now. Go to Midnight Madness.
Be the guest. Go to a big game.
- That's cool. That’s cool. Yeah, man.
- He's the best. Shoutout to him.
Shoutout to Mike.
Shoutout to Max. Everybody.
- Appreciate it. OK. Wooh.
- Yeah, I got you.
I'll make sure I send that to you
so you have, you have it.
- So this what happens when you do your podcast?
- I always have a little somethin’. You know,
shoutout to Bobby cuz me and Bobby were talking about it.
I was like, I know he
likes Michigan State.
We were debating the Giants. I was like,
I'm pretty sure he's a Giants fan.
I was like, but I think he's
more of a Michigan State fan.
So, shoutout to Bobby,
who's in here somewhere
acting like he
don't hear me. But, yeah.
So I'll tell him that you saw that.
Why Michigan State?
- Growing up as a kid just
always watching them on TV.
Like, it wasn't really like
a rhyme or reason. Then,
you know, realizing, you
know, Magic Johnson came out
of there, you know? And then
just watching those NCAA games with,
like, Mateen Cleaves playing for them.
And then, you know, ultimately
watching Draymond play
through there. So it was
just for me, you know,
I just always, you know,
dug the organization.
- Yeah.
- There wasn't really like—it's not no real deep.
It's just—
- Well, you got lucky.
It's a good pick.
Like, that's a good school
to just kind of fall into,
into being a fan of. You at this point,
you are kind of like a
figure in sports culture too,
you know?
Like, you sit courtside at the
games. And I want to ask you
about the process of sitting
courtside because to you,
it probably feels very normal,
but the majority of humans
have never done that.
They've never sat courtside.
They, No. 1,
don't know that once you
sit courtside, you
can't go back.
- It's kind of like first class a little bit.
- I was just about to say.
- Like, oh, this is nice.
- It's like, I'll catch y'all later.
Cuz I ain't going back.
- Fresh cookies. What? Free drinks. What?
- Get the blanket and the
pillow and Delta One.
- You ain't walking past first class no more.
It's tough.
- So why is it? Why is sitting
courtside just, like,
unlike anything. Like, tell
someone who's never been
what it is like.
- I'm coming from a hooper's perspective.
So it's like playing in, like,
tournaments and games and like,
you know, competing, you
know, in organized sports.
When you're sitting courtside,
it's almost like being back at the gym.
You know what I'm saying?
You're hearing the sneakers.
You're hearing the talking,
you know what I'm saying?
You're hearing,
you're paying attention to
the game within the game.
- Yes. Which is the better part.
- That's the part—
listen, I don't even know
if endorsements would
be able to handle, like, paying for audio.
Like, if I can pay for, like,
audio of guys, like, everybody,
everybody loses their brand deals.
Brand deals out of here.
Everything is done actually.
But that part of the game
to experience is—you can't,
it's really hard to explain
to somebody who hasn't been
there, but that's
I think the specialness of
sitting courtside and being—
- Best thing you've heard courtside?
- Oh, I can't say that.
- Oh, it’s a secret?
- No, no.
I mean, it's like out of respect
for like what's being said.
It's, like, really tough.
I think, like, uh, I'm trying to think what, uh...
you know, just having
moments where like, you know,
let's say, like, LeBron or
whatever, and he'll come down.
Not that he tells you
exactly what he's gonna do,
but he insinuates he's about to do it.
And then actually like doing
it and then kind of giving you
a nod like, “I told you so.”
It's like one of those times.
- OK, tell me one of
those moments, like, that
we all saw that you're like he said,
he was about to do this, and he went and did it.
- It was more than on the
defensive end. And it was,
I can't remember the team that
he was playing, but it was,
it was—somebody kept
getting behind, getting
behind the defense or whatever
and had easy layups.
You know what I'm saying?
Somebody wasn't getting
back or something like that.
And I remember him making an
adjustment and actually being
last man back the last
time—I want so say
it was outlet, fast break,
something like that.
And he ended up like, you know,
breaking up a pass or whatever
the case may be. And then,
you know what I'm saying, he got amped up.
Everybody came over and
dapped him up or whatever.
And it was a little like, yeah,
like, I made the adjustment.
Like, his IQ and his court awareness,
you know what I'm saying? And
his basketball IQ is so high.
Like, just knowing what needs
to be done in the adjustments
to be made, I think was really, really,
it was really cool to see
up close and personal.
So that's just a, can't
remember exact moment,
but that's something that I
do remember, you know, him—
- I know totally what you mean. It was,
that was the best part for
me about being in the bubble
cuz you're essentially
courtside every game and
there's no people in there.
So when I say you hear like
the smallest little thing,
it was just great. I had an,
I don't want to say like a
new respect for the game,
cuz I really respect the game,
but I had just like a new
understanding of what it's really
like out there for NBA players
when they're going at it.
So I love, I was like, I'm
never going back either.
I mean,
me getting a ticket a little
different than you getting
a ticket, but I, I mean,
I be down there, though.
- And I do have another moment about Kob, actually.
- Yeah. I’d love to hear it.
- Thinking about that.
It was courtside,
sitting next to him.
I can't remember what game it was, but,
but my experience is kind of the opposite.
He's so locked in. He doesn't break.
So, like, saying what's
up to him in warm-up lines,
all that good stuff was cool.
But then when the game was
on, sitting, like,
two seats away from
him, you know what I mean?
It's just kinda like how focused
he is on what he's in the
middle of and what he's doing.
Even when you try to get,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, you know, “Hey, I’m still sitting here.
Same guy
you said what's up to.
Like, we know each other.
We actually worked together.”
- Like, talk to me.
- Nothing? OK, cool.
It's like you respect the workplace,
you know what I'm saying?
And the drive of like of what
mission he's out on right now.
So that was just like, you know,
the opposite of how—
not the opposite, but just,
he just was so locked in.
It was, it was, you know,
always impressive.
- Yeah, he was, he was different.
When I think about, you know,
being courtside, seeing Kobe
and Gigi courtside together.
And you just know he is
pouring this knowledge into her
about this game that you're
literally not going to get anywhere else.
- Exactly.
- It was just like such
a, such a special moment.
So obviously rest in peace to
Kobe, thinking about Gigi and
his family and all that stuff.
So that's really great that
you were able to have this
courtside experience with him, though.
- It was special.
- And you've had some really
cool courtside experiences.
I know the viral moment of
you and Drake courtside.
What's it like being at a game with Drake?
So I feel like he'd be talking.
- No, I mean, we talk shit.
So it’s, you know,
you’re going to the game with
one of your partners it’s like you,
you know, it’s what you’d be saying
at home, but you're there.
So you actually can talk to
them. So I mean, and so that was,
that was always, that was a good time.
Yeah. Like courtside is
fun when you with, you know,
people who know how to enjoy it.
- Yeah, totally.
- And, yeah, it was a good time.
- Amazing. Last little part for you.
I'm very fascinated by obviously
actors playing these roles,
these roles that probably at
time just feel like huge to play and
You probably take parts of these
characters with you in some
ways. So I just want to name
some of your characters.
Can you tell me what you've
taken from that character that I
named let's start with Killmonger.
- Oh yeah.
That was the one that stuck. I mean, yeah,
still there it's a,
I think the unapologetic
nature of doing what he felt
was right.
I think there was a,
a freeing experience to play
Erik that allowed me to dive
into parts of my personality
that I normally would downplay
or not really.
- Can you tell me what part?
- I think it's the
unapologetic nature of it.
I think there was a certain
level of not giving a fuck
that he had, that I
kind of had to tap into.
- Okay.
I like that.
I re I remember seeing that
you for a bit went to therapy
after you were done playing Killmonger
do you continue to go?
- I do.
- Okay.
I'm a big proponent of therapy.
I think everyone should
at least try it one. Yeah.
- Yeah. I think so.
You know, I think culturally
and generationally,
that is something that has been
lost within our community a
little bit or not really
like, you know, grazed over.
And I, I do think it's helpful
just to unpack a little bit,
- Just to literally talk.
- Yeah.
- Like at its base is just talking,
which I think everyone,
everyone should do.
So I'm glad that one of the
things that role led you to do
was try that. So, so that's
really important for sure.
Okay, Wallace.
- Wallace.
That's wow.
It's gotta be like a hindsight
perspective from that because
I was so young that I
wasn't really, you know,
up until like maybe mid middle
of the season, you know, it,
I tapped into more
where I really kind of like
lost myself in a role instead of
like, feeling like I was acting.
No, I think there's a little
bit like that felt, you know,
so, in hindsight,
to be able to look at the
character and be like,
what I probably took with
me from that is I guess the
vulnerability, you know, I
think he was pretty vulnerable.
- He was and he didn't want
to be in this circumstance.
- I think he, he,
he think he felt the
most out of a lot of the
characters that I've played.
He's probably the most,
you know, raw and emotional.
- Okay. Good answer.
Two more for you.
- Mmhmm.
- Oscar Grant.
- Oscar, man.
- "Fruitvale Station."
- Oscar was—yeah.
Oscar.
Ooh, that—I mean, that kinda, you know,
as a whole kicked off a
whole situ—like, movement,
I felt like.
It's more like a—
because it's a real person,
you know? It wasn't like a,
you know, some fictional
character, you know? Being able
to spend time with his family, you know,
and really get to know him
and understand who he was and,
you know,
meditating on him and asking,
you know, his spirit to kinda be
present with me during that
journey. You know,
it's a tie that's, you know,
that in the performance,
you know, you wanna,
you have to play that day out
like there's gonna be a tomorrow.
- Mm.
- And there's a certain—
- Wow, I never thought about it like that.
- You know what I'm saying?
There's a certain, like...
I don't know how this story ends.
- Yeah.
- So I think what he had to go
through in those moments is
just the frustration of
being treated like this and
the constant misunderstandings,
or the, you know,
desire to just get home.
"I just wanna go home." Like,
"I just wanna get here."
So I think that those frustrations
kinda like, you know—
something that I think was—I
ain't took it with me,
but it's something that
in hindsight again...
yeah. Mmhmm.
- You know, one thing about you
that a lotta people don't do—
I've done a lot of interviews.
You think about—like,
you're very intentional with
whatever your answer is. Like,
you really think about what
your answer is before you say
your answer.
- Mmhmm.
- Which is something you
should always do because, trust me—
- [Laughing] "I'm not sayin' don't do it!"
- Hey, you've done a great job, OK?
Because he thinks about it exactly.
So I appreciate the thoughtfulness
of all your answers,
but before I let you go, I want to ask,
is there anything that you want
to talk about or anything in
your head that you have not
had the chance to discuss, a
question you have not been asked?
And I don't mean today. I mean...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, the past, like, year or so,
I've been intentionally avoiding
a lot of interviews and,
you know,
opportunities to speak on certain stuff
because I felt like I didn't
have anything to say that felt
significant in the sense of,
like, not, let me rephrase that.
I didn't feel like talking
about anything that was
insignificant.
- Mmhmm.
- I was like,
there's too much going on
right now to be talking about
these other things that in my
mind right now don't matter
as much.
So, you know, and then
having to, I guess, you know,
working on directing, you know,
and getting this next project,
and that's kind of been,
that's kind of consumed my life, you know.
Lately I've kinda, you know, just...
you see so many things that's
going on and is wrong, you know, or not wrong
but just things that need to
be addressed in a real way with,
like, the right type of questions.
And though that wasn't interesting
enough to places to want
to talk about, you know, or...
- Mmhmm.
- You know,
it wasn't presented in the
right way. You gotta, you gotta...
you can't be emotional.
You just gotta be responsible
with your emotions and how you
feel, like, knowing where, where
we stand, where we sit,
the voice that we have.
It's, you know,
sometimes it's better just not
to say anything and just go
and just be in your world for a while
until you're ready to address the system.
You know, what we're doing.
You know, like this is a,
you know, this is what we do.
Like, you know, we,
we're the messenger a lot of times,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- Like, we have a responsibility.
So I just felt like, you know,
I could be more productive
getting some work done.
And then when it's time for
me to talk about and readdress
those things and things that
I felt like were important,
we could do that then. So…
- OK. Well, I—
- And I'm being vague enough.
- You're being very, yeah, but it feels...
- But I'm still, you know,
letting you know that, you know,
that there, to answer
your question plainly,
there hasn't been a question
that I wanted to really answer.
- OK.
Fair. No, I'm with you.
- Yeah.
- I see it. Well, I will close.
I know I read a lot. I have
a bunch of random quotes,
but what that makes me
think of is, you know,
the quote "Until the lion has a
historian, history will always
be told from the point
of view of the hunter."
- Mmhmm.
- And I think something that's
really special about what I'm
able to do too
but really what you're able to
do with storytelling is you get
to be a lion and a historian.
- Mmm.
- I think that's so great.
And you have really been,
I just think a representation
for people to see the things
that are possible
but also the stories that are
possible. And diversifying the
things that we see.
Cuz for so long rolls of Black people,
Black men were one thing.
- Mmhmm.
- And as people like you
that really open that
space up for everybody,
not just to, like, be in
those rooms but to see it.
So, and I know that you know
that, but just, you know,
- No.
- continuing to do, you know,
all the things that you do
is so incredibly important.
And I loved this, and I hope that you
- Same.
- were able to get, you know,
things out of it as well.
Cuz interviews should be,
they should be mutual. You should feel,
you should feel heard as well.
- Anytime. Appreciate all that.
And we'll definitely do more.
- Yeah.
Absolutely. Well, hey,
I'm ready for the Classic.
- OK.
- That's what I know.
- That's what I'm talking about.
- We gonna be in Newark.
- That's right.
Prudential Center.
- Yes.
- Invesco QQQ Legacy Classic.
- Yeah, Invesco QQQ.
So people who want to watch the Classic
in person,
- Mmhmm.
- not on TNT, how do they do it?
- December 18th, go to
Prucenter.com/legacy-classic.
And then you can buy
tickets there, and yeah,
it's pretty straightforward
and simple.
- Yeah.
- Prudential Center in Newark,
New Jersey, the Invesco QQQ
Legacy Classic.
- There we go. We in there.
- We in the building.
- [Laughing]